[Musique]
bonsoir mardi 5 mai bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition spéciale sur tv 78
cette carte d'abord celle du
déconfinement qui sera figé ce jeudi à
sa dernière parution hier les yvelines
comme le reste de l'île de france
étaient encore en rouge
ce qui veut dire que la circulation du
corona virus reste actif dans le
département et que subsiste toujours une
tension hospitalière sur les services de
réanimation et d'après les données de
santé publique france paru hier 437
personnes sont mortes du coronavirus
dans les hôpitaux yvelinois depuis le
début de la crise on dénombre 793
hospitalisation sur le territoire c'est
en léger recul comme pour les
réanimations et puis à 1480 le nombre de
patients guéris dans les yvelines est
revenu à domicile les écoles maternelles
et primaires doivent rouvrir
progressivement à partir de lundi
prochain jour du début du déconfinement
à six jours de la rentrée emmanuel
macron s'est rendu ce matin à poissy
le président de la république était à
l'école pierre de ronsard pour faire le
point sur l'organisation du retour en
place en compagnie du ministre de
l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer air et visites dans les
yvelines où 67 maires ont signé une
tribune et dénonçant une reprise à
marche forcée et demandant un report le
chef d'état qui a pu échanger avec
certains de ses élus a tenu à rassurer
la rentrée sera sans contrainte et
progressive il s'est exprimé à l'issue
de ce déplacement
ce que nous avons voulu c'est que dans
cette phase qui s'ouvre le 11 mai le
retour comme je les dis le 13 avril
dernier progressif et concerté puisse se
faire alors pourquoi parce que dans la
vie d'un enfant resté deux mois à la
maison même si un formidable travail et
je vais revenir qui se fait à distance
c'est quand même très traumatisant donc
les maires je comprends leur angoisse je
comprends leurs questions leurs
inquiétudes mais ils veulent bien faire
et donc faut leur laisser le temps de
bien faire et la souplesse
j'étais à l'instant avec des maires qui
parfois ont signé les tribunes tous
m'ont dit nous on veut rouvrir
j'ai pas un maire avec qui j'ai parlé
aujourd'hui qui m'a dit nous ne voulons
pas rouvrir certains m'ont dit on va
réussir à ouvrir dès le 12 le maire des
mureaux m 10 des 12 jurés ouvrir mais
pour les familles qui sont les plus en
difficulté la semaine d'après ge élargir
et encore un peu je vais y aller
prudemment
mais je sais les familles en difficulté
je vais les privilégiés un autre m'a dit
peut-être que j'aurai plus de confort si
je peux ouvrir le 14
le tout c'est que les mères avec leurs
directeurs d'école leurs enseignants
soit sur une position commune concertée
et que les parents soient bien informés
parce que c'est très important que la
vie familiale professionnelle s'organise
et que donc d'ici à la fin de semaine
chaque parent soit informé de comment ça
marche dans sa commune et pour son école
l'école pierre de ronsard ou depuis le
début du confinement environ 30 enfants
de personnels soignants sont accueillis
le maire se dit favorable à la rentrée
des classes
tout sera prêt dans sa ville at il
affirmé karl olive que nous sommes pas
parvenus à joindre aujourd'hui est mais
qui sait tout de même exprimé et qui a
réagi sur son compte twitter une matinée
qui a permis à chacun selon l'édile de
réaliser que la réouverture des écoles
peut être possible grâce au volontariat
des parents et en faisant confiance aux
élus de terrain certains syndicats et
associations de professeurs et de
parents d'élèves s'inquiètent des
conditions de cette reprise notamment le
snuipp fsu 78 qui concerne les
instituteurs du premier degré
le syndicat estime que le protocole de
retour à l'école et inapplicable
notamment sur la distanciation social à
faire respecter un protocole jugé
contraire à l'éthique des professionnels
et qui ne se préoccupe pas du
développement un psychomoteur et
neuropsychologiques et des enfants dit
le snuipp fsu des courriers ont été
adressés aux parents et à la direction
académique des yvelines un plan de
déconfinement qui ne passe pas également
pour les parlementaires il a été adopté
par les députés il ya quelques jours
mais hier lundi les sénateurs ont rejeté
le texte lors des discussions sur le
projet de loi prorogeant l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
89 voix contre 81 une pour et 174
abstentions dont beaucoup d'élus les
républicains et centriste parmi eux le
sénateur des yvelines michel laugier
conseiller départemental et ancien maire
de montigny le bretonneux
une prise de position symbolique pour
dénoncer les manque de précision du
premier ministre sur ce plan et
notamment sur le rôle des élus locaux
écoutez c'est plus une position de
principe parce que il ya beaucoup trop
de certitudes ne sera déjà que les
masques on sait pas c'est tout le monde
vend un masque il ya aussi cette
cacophonie sur la rentrée scolaire
attend toujours au sommet un protocole
de sécurité sanitaire de 75
recommandations mais c'est très
compliqué pour les élus en place de
pouvoir qu'est cela donc voilà tout
c'est parce que vous avez tout ça que
démissionner dans un bon banc de
solidarité tout le monde doit travailler
pour faire sortir le pays de cette
situation
eh bien il faut aussi que remarque notre
différence d'ailleurs on a fait sur le
plan de confinement mais en ce moment
depuis hier après midi
nous examinons au sénat la loi qui va
avec son demande beaucoup aujourd'hui au
maire d'ambarès fait poser le coup c'est
pour ça que nous souhaitons aussi que on
dégage leur responsabilité pénale
l'osce qui vont appliquer des directives
venues de l'état
50e jours de confinement et à quelques
jours du processus de déconfinement de
plus en plus de communes des yvelines
s'organisent pour distribuer des masques
à leurs administrés est depuis le début
de la semaine à trappes des agents
municipaux se déplace dans chaque foyer
le reportage daury lire 11 et de patrick
jacques de dixmude restait qu'à sion le
courrier événements depuis le début de
la semaine les agents municipaux de
trappes met sous pli les masques
destinés aux habitants afin d'anticiper
le déconfinement la ville a fait
l'acquisition de trente mille masques
lavables
ça permet aux personnes de se protéger
des deux est déjà ce sont des masques
réutilisables mais ça me paraît une
démarche normale que font d'ailleurs un
certain nombre de communes de masque en
tissu conforme aux recommandations afnor
sont distribués en mains propres aux
habitants un mode de distribution
volontairement choisi par la mairie
je pense que ce type de démarche de
porte à porte et une démarche qui permet
en même temps d'entendre certain nombre
de remarques d'un certain nombre de
questions et les les agents municipaux
qui ont fait ce travail me rendront
compte de je veux dire des remontées si
le logement héberge plus de deux
personnes les trappistes peuvent
demander des masques supplémentaires dès
aujourd'hui sur le site de la ville
et cet après midi le conseil
départemental des yvelines a lancé
également sa campagne de distribution de
masques en tissu sur le territoire
cela a démarré dans le canton
d'aubergenville un million de protection
en tout à destination des habitants des
communes de moins de 15000 habitants de
masques seront remis à chaque yvelinois
concernés coût total de l'opération 2,5
millions d'euros
eux sont autorisés justement à vendre
des masques grand public depuis quelques
jours les buralistes sont pas remis
et commerces pouvant rester ouverts
pendant le confinement est depuis
quelques semaines ils voient leur
activité augmenter c'est ce dont parle
or ils iront avec son invité
jean-françois vigouroux bonjour vous
êtes le président des buralistes des
yvelines alors depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire les bureaux de tabac
font partie des rares commerces à avoir
été autorisé à rester ouverts bien sûr
en respectant les gestes barrière alors
quelle est la situation justement dans
les yvelines notamment combien de
bureaux sont restés ouverts
on n'a pas trop le chiffre
le chiffre a mais bon on pense que il ya
eu à peu près 60% de tabac qui sont
restés ouverts
il ya eu un moment assez difficile à qui
a été fin mars où on a eu le pic de
fermeture personnellement je suis resté
ouvert tout le temps et on a eu vraiment
beaucoup beaucoup d'affluence
pourquoi justement se pique de fermeture
ce que vous avez le nom le pic de
fermeture a dû
bien entendu à certains personne qui
était malade
certains buralistes qui était malade et
aussi par la peur de tomber malade et
parce que nous étions un commerce qui
avait la possibilité de rester ouverts
mais nous n'avions pas l'obligation de
rester ouvert il fallait bien sûr se
protéger et là était problème c'est que
quand quand tout est arrivé
malheureusement les plexiglas les gants
des masques
bon on en trouvait le prouveront
personnes si on n'avait pas été un peu
prévoyants malheureusement on pouvait
pas ouvrir dans de bonnes conditions
au niveau de l'activité ce que vous avez
constaté un surplus d'activité depuis le
début du confinement
alors depuis en fait depuis l'annnonce
le 16 mars du confinement
on a eu un
un très gros pics de consommation qui
s'est étendu en plus d'un mois et en
fait on met ça aussi sur le dos dans du
duc ovide 19 parce que dans les yvelines
nous avons beaucoup de personnes qui
habitent et yves lainé qui vont
travailler sur paris et qui peuvent
acheter leur tabac sur paris étant
confiné dans les yvelines ils se sont
retrouvés à acheter leur tabac dans des
endroits où il acheté pas avant il ya ce
phénomène là le phénomène aussi que les
gens ne pouvaient pas se les procurer
par des par des amis qui pouvait aller à
l'étranger et aussi par la contrebande
est aussi parlé par internet
si certains pouvaient les recevoir par
la poste étant donné que tout ce qui
était colis c'était aussi saturé
donc on a retrouvé des clients qui
n'avaient pas l'habitude de venir chez
nous tant qu'ils ne connaissaient pas le
prix qu'ils connaissaient pas vraiment à
déterrer la dénomination du produit etc
donc nous attendons les chiffres de
logista qui devrait nous dire en
fonction des voiles et une sortie la
progression mais ce qui est certain
c'est que on a au moins une progression
de 25 à 30% sur les yvelines les
buralistes sont autorisés à vendre des
masques justement j'imagine que la
demande est forte
oui la demande est très forte au niveau
des masques on nous les demande tous les
jours nous en avons à vendre depuis
depuis la semaine dernière on nous
annonce que nous allons vendre des
masques
malheureusement la confédération a tout
mis en place pour se procurer des
masques auprès d'une entreprise
française de picardie dont des masques
100% français des masques lavables et
réutilisables 15 fois malheureusement on
est
on a été victime du succès car les deux
millions de masques ont été vendus en
auprès des buralistes en moins de 48
heures et après c'est la geôle
logistique pour fournir les buralistes
qui ne qui ne suit pas et donc nous
sommes toujours dans l'attenté de
recevoir les masques dans les jours qui
viennent ce sont des masques anti sûr
c'est bien ça bascule en tissu
réutilisables normes et afnor catégorie
2 donc
et je répète 100% français quand vous
parlez de deux millions c'est deux
millions pour pour les yvelines non 2
millions pour nom pour la la
confédération des buralistes pour les
24000 buralistes donc on pouvait en
acheter autant qu'on voulait mais bien
sûr ça va deux millions c'est un film il
aurait fallu si on en avait eu trois ou
quatre fois plus si on les a revendues
la même façon soit une dernière question
pour les masquer ce que vous limitez le
nombre de masques par par client
peut-être un ou deux par client ou pas
forcément sur le format c'est une
politique que j'ai avec la confédération
on favorise surtout les les artisans et
les commerçants qui en auraient besoin
pour fonctionner dans leur entreprise
donc afin de satisfaire sa nous avons
décidé de mettre la moitié de ce qu'on
va recevoir deux côtés pour la clientèle
pour les artisans les commerçants ceux
qui s'en serviraient à titre
professionnel mais après nous avons des
gens qui qui peuvent nous en prendre
trois ou quatre voilà ça reste dans des
mesures bien sûr si un client vient nous
en demander d'ici on va on va pas lui et
on va lui dire gentiment qu' il vaut
mieux en acheter trois ou quatre des
pipes en avoir un peu pour tout le monde
merci et jean-françois vigouroux en tout
cas pour toutes ces explications je
rappelle que vous êtes le président des
buralistes des yvelines
merci beaucoup excellente soirée et
connaissions un secteur qui lui souffre
en cette période de confinement c'est
celui du cinéma avec 311 salle dans la
région et plus de 140 mille emplois
concernés d'autant que le 73e festival
de cannes qui devait se tenir du 12 au
23 mai a été reportée
tout comme son traditionnel marché du
film qui se déroulera en version aulnat
du 22 au 26 juin prochain événement ô
combien important pour les douze mille
professionnels du cinéma qui se
retrouvent sur place chaque année depuis
plusieurs années le réalisateur plaisir
wa quentin dupuis se rend au marché du
film pour trouver et des financements
pour ses productions il a été interrogé
par mathilde de dominer la situation est
compliquée notamment pour beaucoup de
sociétés audiovisuelles comme la mienne
en tant qu'amateur avec un tournage donc
forcément c'est compliqué de faire des
films quand ya pas de tournage mais on
profite de ce temps avec mes assiettes
des actifs travaillent pour pour écrire
a notamment des nouveaux projets de
nouveaux scénarios pour faire du montage
sur des projets existants voilà on ne
trouve quand même le moyen de continuer
à faire des choses même si c'est vrai
qu'en terme de tournage a pour l'instant
on est comme tout le monde confiné chez
nous et attendre de voir comment les
choses vont évoluer comme beaucoup
puissamment retravailler ils ont été
fermés dès le début du confinement les
jardins à partager ou jardins dits
familiaux ont peu à peu rouverts c'est
le cas à 26 le bretonneux où les
jardiniers amateurs peuvent de nouveau
s'occuper de leurs parcelles en
respectant bien sûr des règles précises
aurélie ronze et patrick jacques de
dixmude les pommes de terre sont en paix
là
depuis quelques semaines les jardins
familiaux de montigny le bretonneux
peuvent de nouveau accueillir leurs
locataires
il avait été fermé dès le début du
confinement au départ seuls les
propriétaires de poules avait obtenu une
dérogation pour venir nourrir leurs
animaux grâce à une autorisation de la
préfecture il est désormais possible de
jardiner depuis la mi avril
une centaine de membres est concerné
chaque jardiner en fait à sa spécificité
on peut dire et donc chacun voulait être
plutôt favorisée afin de penser qu'à son
cas personnel pratiquement en tant qu il
fallait concilier tous ces petits cas
personnel et trouver un compromis en
s'accordant avec les directives
préfectorales
donc on a abouti à deux heures les
propriétaires de gallinacés peuvent
continuer à venir entre 9h et 10h pour
les jardiniers le créneau est compris
entre 17 heures et 19 heures avec
toutefois des règles précises la chance
que l'on a à montigny c'est que les
jardins sont tous numérotés
il a été décidé que les jardiniers qui
avait une parcelle numéros pairs jardine
ray les jours pairs et les numéros
impairs les jours impairs de ce fait que
les jardiniers pas cultivant n'étant pas
côte à côte
la municipalité a également mis en place
des contrôles de police afin de veiller
au bon respect de ce nouveau règlement
et puis cette initiative solidaire pour
terminer des scooters à disposition des
personnels soignants et aussi des
formations gratuites à la conduite c'est
l'initiative d'un chef d'entreprise
spécialisé dans les formations aux deux
roues philippe monneret répond aux
questions de wilfrid richy pilote moto
vainqueur des 24 heures notamment ou
encore record man en 2015 de vitesse sur
circuit en atteignant 3 157 km heure
philippe monneret est également
fondateur de l'entreprise
easy monneret qui propose des formations
de pilotage des formations permis moto
ou encore des stages de perfectionnement
est l'une des agences se trouvent
notamment sur le circuit beltoise à
trappes philippe monneret bonjour
bonjour le siège social de votre
entreprise est basée sur paris mais vous
proposez vos services notamment sur
toute l'île de france est et donc sur
les yvelines
nous sommes en ligne avec vous
aujourd'hui pour évoquer votre
initiative le personnel soignant
travaillant dans un hôpital public ou
privé en établissement médical peut
disposer d'un scooter qui lui est livré
sur son lieu de travail ou de résidence
pourquoi tout d'abord cette opération eh
ben on était avec mon fils si on se
disait qu'on était nuls qu'on faisait
rien pour ces gens qui étaient
particulièrement dévouée donc on a
cherché moi j'ai pas trouvé c'est lui
qui a trouvé et qui s'est dit iran sion
pretend scooter parce que ils sont
immobilisés
là ça fait déjà trois semaines on est
plutôt en fin de parcours mais on a
rajouté quelque chose qui était
nécessaire à mon goût pour justement le
déconfinement parce que ça y est on y
arrive on lui confie nom vaut bien en
sortir c'était cette offre de formation
125 vous savez c'est cette petite
formation 7 heures obligatoires quand on
a un permis voiture depuis deux ans et
dont on s'est dit on va leur offrir
cette formation pendant toute l'année
2020 donc qu'il puisse déjà être
autonome et surtout se protéger parce
que le potentiel c'est le deux roues qui
vient vous protéger les gens parce qu'on
est confiné sur un deux roues c'est
super on a un autre casque intégral la
visière fermé des gants un blouson et
voilà on va là pour un autre alors je
suis pas contre le vélo bien au
contraire j'en fais mais quand on doit
transporter des ordis quand on est un
peu plus loin quand on est un pandore de
parking le vélo c'est un peu plus
compliqué donc c'est bien aussi de
pouvoir rouler en deux roues et on va on
veut vraiment à la fois inciter tous
personnels pour se protéger à faire du
deux roues éviter de prendre les
transports en commun tel succès
rencontré cette opération justement vous
l'avez dit depuis trois semaines déjà
sur la mise à disposition de vos de vaud
scooter alors en 125 ça a été plus
difficile parce qu'il y avait pas mal de
gens qui avaient pas fait pas cette
formation seat a perdu et bien de de le
faire en revanche on a prêté les 50
voilà mais les 125 c'était un peu plus
compliqué parce qu'il manquait ce
diplôme en tout cas ceux qui l'ont
utilisé était ravie parce que ça va
changer la vie
c'est vrai qu'on a vu beaucoup de
reportages à la télé ou où c'était
compliqué il y avait parfois deux heures
de transport parce qu'il ya des temps
d'attendre les transports en commun etc
et je pense que le deux roues c'est
l'engin idéal pour se déplacer d'un
point à un autre
bien sûr en avec des conditions de
sécurité à mon comportement et bien
équipés mais mais c'est parfait c'est ce
qui vaut pour la ville le dos rond mais
c'est ce qu'il faudra aussi il faut
relancer votre activité qu'il ya un
engouement aussi autour du d'euros vous
l'avez dit l'activité est à l'arrêt là
pendant cette période peut-être sur un
rebond d'activité avec le début du
déconfinement ou alors on l'espère parce
que
quand même hein il va avoir un problème
économique je pense à la à la reprise
mais bon nous on est même une école qui
est là depuis de nombreuses années voilà
lui il ya eu mon ami nos moniteurs en
chômage partiel donc on va reprendre les
des gens qui font que nous appeler pour
nous dire non alors quand est-ce qu'on
finit le permis quand est ce qu on
refait du perfectionnement du pilotage
sur circuit
ils sont les starting blocks amant et
ils ont envie de ce que la moto s'arrête
il ya le côté pratique mais ont aussi le
côté passion qu'il faut pas perdre et ça
le côté passion c'est pas en deux mois
de confinement compères ça c'est clair
hélas pour votre activité vous n'avez
pas d'inquiétude quant au redémarrage ou
en tout cas pour cette période de
blocage est quasi totale je suis pas
inquiet de nature donc voilà on fait un
scénar on a traversé une crise mais tout
va devoir repartir et puis il va falloir
aussi vivre avec ce virus donc on a mis
les choses en place on a mis certaines
choses les gestes barrière mais un peu
plus poussée dans notre école donc les
moniteurs avec des masques les élèves
doivent venir avec dans un premier temps
bac leurs équipements les modos admettre
demain etc
on a tous fait les bureaux pour
l'instant jusqu'au 1er juin
on va les laisser fermer seules les
pistes seront ce sera au sort ont ouvert
parce que nous notre particularité c'est
que nos bureaux sont sur des circuits
vous avez signalé pour trappe
mais on est à meudon au paul ricard à
montlhéry donc c'est n'est vraiment une
moto école où le bureau l'administratif
et directement sur la piste les gens
apprennent et quand tu commences à
savoir techniquement être au x man au
point il sort quand circulation c'est
comme ça que ça se passe chez nous alors
je rappelle vos deux opérations la mise
à disposition des scooters 125 lorsque
le permis est détenu bien personnelle et
50 voilà que le permis est détenu pour
les 125 sur les chieuses pour le
personnel soignant et puis aussi ses
formations ses stages pour les 125 que
vous allez proposer dès le début du
déconfinement gratuitement sur l'année
2020 j'ai trouvé parce que ça c'était le
côté la solidarité qu'on voulait avoir
les avis du personnel soignant
ce que bon
avec ses presque anecdotique les le prêt
de scooter mais est là en revanche je
pense qu'on va avoir beaucoup beaucoup
de monde tout cas on a énormément de
demandes pour la formation 125 et ça
c'est bien et on est content aussi de
faire ça pour eux parce qu'ils le
méritent pas si philippe monneret
fondateur donc dizy monneret plus
d'informations sur votre activité et
tous ses services sur votre site
internet
easy monneret point com merci à vous
merci à vous et c'est l'occasion de dire
une nouvelle fois un énorme bravo à tous
les personnels soignants et aussi à tous
ceux engagés en première ligne de cette
lutte contre le coronavirus voilà c'est
la fin de cette édition spéciale merci
de votre fidélité restez chez vous et
très belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]
tous